i would notice over the years no matter
where i was working whatever market i
worked in and whatever station i worked
for there was always that don't make the
sponsors the people paying for the
commercials mad
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
former television news journalist and
now candidate for governor of the great
state of arizona carrie lake welcome to
the reuben report hi dave thank you for
having me i'm so excited to be here
carrie i have to start very obviously my
audience is going to hear former
television journalists they're going to
freak out because they don't like
journalists am i am i allowed to call
you a former journalist without using
air quotes because you know journalists
these days i think you get it i well i
came up through the old school of
journalism where you you told both sides
of the story if there were three sides
you told all three sides and you kept
your opinions out
and that's why i walked away from my
career i i started in journalism 30
years ago and that's how you did it and
now we've increasingly seen journalists
moving on out being replaced with
propagandists
and i was at the top of my game number
one in ratings for pretty much my entire
time covering arizona most recently 22
years at the fox affiliate number one
that whole time making a fortune
had a pretty good life and then coveted
struck and i realized there are no good
guys in the corporate media
if there were good guys they would have
covered ivermectin told us about
hydroxychloroquine they would have been
honest about the election and the
corruption involved in that
and i i just you know i looked up in my
career and said oh my gosh i can't do
this anymore i don't want to be part of
this it was getting increasingly more
difficult to be honest with the people
of arizona and if i couldn't speak 100
percent truth i didn't want to be part
of it so i walked away i i do think
there are some good journalists out
there the ones you're seeing on the
corporate media unfortunately are mainly
propagandists today do you remember a
moment that you started getting an
inkling of all that did it really start
with covet or i suspect in 22 years you
probably saw some other hints leading to
where we got to today
you know the news has increasingly been
moving toward the left obviously over
the past many decades and and i just
always felt like well as long as i keep
what comes out of my mouth and when i'm
being a journalist i can keep that
straight on the straight and narrow and
make sure that i'm being fair i can't
always
be responsible for everybody else that
works in the industry but i know i can
be responsible for myself and i really
truly felt that i could do that for the
most part almost all the time and so
that's what kept me going in my career
you know there's always that that
i guess it would be the law of
television broadcasting and really any
uh news entity they want to protect
their sponsors and i would notice over
the years no matter where i was working
whatever market i worked in and whatever
station i worked for there was always
that don't make the sponsors the people
paying for the commercials mad for
example if a big uh
car car company in town uh if there was
a scandal somehow it was always
you know pulling teeth to get management
to want to cover something like that
they would maybe cover it if they had to
but it would be a short 20-second
version of the story rather than
covering it ad nauseam like they would
if it was somebody who wasn't a sponsor
and looking back you you see things like
that and you go wow that's a really
dangerous thing because we saw this
during covet
these news outlets took hundreds of
millions of dollars from fauci
and big pharma and
you almost saw it happening you almost
saw it like this like somebody flipped a
switch and they all started talking so
positively about the vaccines
and there was no critical coverage of it
now i'm not trying to be judgmental on a
vaccine but it is our responsibility as
journalists to put out the truth and not
to tout a product
and not to refuse to cover the dangerous
side effects because the people are
counting on truth from journalism at
least they used to
and so when you see all these tv people
and and newspaper people putting out
only the positives and trying to shame
people into getting shots but not
covering the true side effects and there
are some very dangerous side effects
with these shots i believe they have
blood on their hands and i'm so thankful
that i got out before that business
started up because i was watching that
happen with horror knowing specifically
people who had terrible side effects and
actually blamed
relatives deaths on those shots and then
sitting there and watching journalists
tout them and and pump them up like they
were the greatest thing i think it's
disgraceful and hinging on criminal
are you amazed how they can sort of do
it right in front of our eyes i don't
know if you've seen that compilation
that was going viral for a while we've
shown it a couple times on my show where
they show you all the outros to the
commercials the intros and outros to the
commercials on mainstream media cnn cbs
morning news et cetera brought to you by
pfizer the same people who are telling
you how wonderful pfizer is the entire
time i thought at one time we were
supposed to be skeptical about this
stuff
i saw that i saw that compilation at
first i didn't believe it because
sometimes you see these compilations you
go that can't be true but
i was just watching i was uh leaving uh
north carolina a day ago and i was
watching one of the major networks
morning show and they were talking about
the teen suicide rate and teen mental
illness and all of that and and they did
a whole segment on it and what to look
out for you know they didn't talk about
what caused a lot of it which was these
uh draconian shutdowns and lockdowns and
quarantines unnecessarily in the masking
of our teenagers which wasn't needed and
caused all kinds of mental problems and
sending them home they didn't talk about
that they just talked about how we've
got teens with a bunch of emotional
issues now and right out of it was an ad
for i forget which big pharma about a
drug for
um depression and suicide and all of
that and i'm like wow it's so obvious
once your eyes are woken up to it but
some people just aren't awake yet dave
some people are not awake there's a lot
of woke people just not a lot of awake
people that that seems to be the problem
uh you did an event about two weeks ago
here in florida i was going to try to
get there and then something popped up
but you were at mar-a-lago with a
certain orange man who will play a
10-second we'll play a quick 10-second
clip here's what he had to say about you
but i will say that i think that's going
to be one of the great things that i've
done endorsing a woman and helping her
get elected and i think she'll go down
as the greatest governor
[Applause]
all right so it looks like you've got or
not looks like you've got the
endorsement of trump you've done events
with him um
how does that feel relative to getting
into politics for the first time and
just the general state of craziness and
the circus that is our political machine
well that sound bite that you just
played was just um
it felt really good to hear that because
i i do plan on being the best governor
best governor arizona's ever seen i'll
probably be the first governor arizona's
ever seen that truly was in it for the
right reasons to represent the great
people of this state so when he said
he's gonna one of his greatest
accomplishments will be to help get me
elected and and he knows i'll become the
greatest one of the greatest governors
in the country um that made me feel
really good because i'm in this for the
right reason i trust me there's no
reason you'd want to get into the
corrupt world of the swampy politics
unless you're doing it for the right
reason i i'm not in it for the fame
there's no money in it if you're an
honest person and you're not trying to
you know build the taxpayers out of
their money
i'm just doing this because i love
arizona and i looked at the field of
people who was running dave
and i believe this is the last election
in this country if we don't get it right
and we don't get some america first
people in there running some honest
citizen politicians i don't know that
we'll have a country beyond this
election so i looked at the field of who
was running and it's the typical rhino a
career politician somebody who's run
before lost 20 years ago we have
somebody who's run before
and run against katie hobbs who's going
to be the democrat socialist that we end
up running against and he already lost
to her a few years ago so i looked at
the field of republicans running and i
said not a single one of them can get us
past the finish line and if we lose this
election and we get a katie hobbs who is
a socialist democrat we will lose
arizona and we cannot as a country
afford to lose another border state if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell